what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel then feel free
to subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
so as we continue our discussions on
all-new all-different marvel what I want
to do here is I want to talk about
all-new all-different Silver Surfer now
again much like the rest of Marvel's
lineup from before Secret Wars Silver
Surfer just kind of continues on but
dance Lots handling of Silver Surfer was
actually designed to sort of create this
secret origin that nobody really knew
about in terms of the background aspect
of shallow bald as well as Norrin Radd
himself now with regards to him
sacrificing his life in order to become
The Herald of Galactus that all pretty
much stays the same but when it came to
no one rad and it came to you know
zenn-la as a planet there were a lot of
things we didn't know and so Dan Slott
basically expands on this now one of the
things that we initially do is we pick
up with the father of a girl named Don
Greenwood along with her sister who's
waiting on Don's return now with the
character of Don Greenwood she was a
creation strictly by Dan Slott as a way
to basically test the waters with a love
interest of Silver Surfer because
there's really been the bane of his
existence ever since he became a silver
surfer ever since Norrin Radd left his
life behind and ever since shahla valle
was believed to have been dead the idea
was that he always had a mishmash of
women in his life especially Alicia
masters who will actually play a role in
the story but it was never really
anything long-lasting a Don Greenwood
was designed to be that way and the way
that Dan Slott did this is he created a
new cosmic entity called the queen of
Nevers when it comes to wishes in the
realm of Marvel Comics wishes are really
just just nonsense they never really had
any validity the only time wishes ever
really mattered is when you had
something like the Cosmic Cube which was
basically a wishing box and whatever it
is that you wanted to do as long as you
had the Cosmic Cube would come to
fruition even if it defied the laws of
physics but with the Don Greenwood and
the creation of the queen of Nevers came
a realm called the dimension of the
realm of shouldn't be never be or never
be shouldn't be or something like that
but it was basically where all
possibilities exist and it's really
metaphorical but it was basically Dan
Slott saying you know here is a
character named Don Greenwood she
basically wished for a life of
excitement shooting it up wishing on
what she thought was a star turned out
to be the solar surfer at the same time
the Silver Surfer had this premonition
that he was that he was going to
encounter a woman who was the most
important woman in the universe and
ultimately it led to him encountering
dawn Greenwood now following this of
course dawn was taken by the queen of
Nevers and it ran into this really
really weird story arc that was really
just designed to both introduce dawn as
well as provide us or segue into the
last days of Silver Surfer leading to
the collapse of the multiverse but with
the with the Secret Wars launch we
basically just pick up with Silver
Surfer as he's your own cruising the
spaceways with dawn and so she's
designed to kind of be this comedic
element to his character and was
designed to take the the concept of
Silver Surfer and basically make it
funnier than it had been in the past and
so what we have here is this the
circumstance whereby the the father of
Dawn her know her twin sister Eve
they're basically waiting for Dawn's
return but then the plan is suddenly met
by the arrival of a race of alien so the
race of aliens say that they're
effectively going to take everything
that the world values they're going to
take everything that that people hold on
to which is basically is like memories
music TV shows different things like
that and they quite literally take the
substance that makes these things and
pull them away and the result is that
while this is happening the Silver
Surfer
and Dawn basically step in and of course
are able to fight these aliens off and
they're able to send them on their way
now the device that these aliens are
using initially strikes a strikes a
chord with a silver surfer because he
believes he's seen it before but the
aliens are basically forced into retreat
and and of course Silver Surfer and dawn
head back to earth in order for dawn to
basically visit her family and that's
all this really is you know the first
half of the story is really just dawn
spending time with her family you know
spending time with her father spending
time with her sister it's also you know
NORAD becoming acclimated to the world
as it exists in terms of spending more
time with normal people where the
problem is that almost immediately after
this happens you know these threads of
memories these threads of stories these
threads of everything that makes makes
up culture on the planet Earth begin to
become stripped away and where Silver
Surfer goes and he attacks use aliens a
second time and he's able to to fight
them off you know successfully he also
comes to the realization that this
device is again something that he needs
to investigate because he knows or at
least he has an idea
of what it is now exactly what this
device is is something that we find out
here in a minute but what we do is we
transition to a place called planet
Alana's and implanted Alana's we of
course have been Graham now with Ben
Grimm he had previously become part of
the guardians of the galaxy now the
issue here is that with Secret Wars her
after Secret Wars he was just kind of a
no-man's land and no one really knew
what to do with him and so Dan Slott
basically took over the character who
said I'll grab Ben Grimm I will give him
purpose not only that Ben Grimm has
always had a very close relationship
with the Silver Surfer just by Accenture
the Fantastic Four you know when it
comes to Marvel comics the Fantastic
Four Galactus and the Silver Surfer are
kind of this trifecta of cosmic
exploration and adventure and so yes one
of the reasons why whenever there's a
Fantastic Four story Galactus is not too
far behind in terms of making an
appearance or being mentioned or
somewhere along those lines but were Ben
Grimm crash lands on this planet he's
immediately met by the arrival of a
person that declares themselves to be
the keeper of the great truth and so we
don't know initially who this person is
but this individual is basically able to
use their abilities to bend Ben Graham
it to their whim to effectively turn it
into somebody who's subservient and so
from here we actually jump back to the
past a little bit and this is when the
this is when we get this this sort of
secret origin of Norn lad in a sense
that with shallow ball and the wind
betrothed and you know preparing
themselves to be married the other half
of this is that Norrin Radd and shallow
ball both secretly stolen robbed as he
seeks adventure he seeks life outside of
zenn-la and so where he initially tells
Chalobah we should take one of these
jets and we should leave this ties into
the nature of his character but they're
also met by the arrival of the keeper of
the great truth now to sidetrack here
for a second Argost is not really a side
track with the keeper to get truth what
he really says here with new and rad and
he just basically fills in what it was
it I was going to say a second ago is
that there was a point where by the
people of Zen law had experienced war
and conflict much like what we
experience here on earth but over the
course of their existence they had you
know explored out to the Stars they had
basically discovered everything there
was to discover and the result was he
retreated back into themselves and
ultimately you sort of lead to the
downfall of zenn-la to the point where
it really became a question of a can
they function adequately you know can
they really even exist on a fundamental
or have they lost what it was that
passes for human with regards to you
know how they how they view all things
in existence and so ultimately the
keeper of the great truth is essentially
this keeper of all knowledge if you guys
have read The Giver
by by Lois Lowry I think it was who put
that together it's basically this this
circumstance whereby the keeper of the
great truth is basically the giver he
holds on to all the knowledge of the
past of these and lobby ins and
basically keeps it for their own records
as a reminder of the dangers that they
could find themselves falling towards if
they ever went back to their more
primitive ways and so from here you know
nor dad doesn't really recall a whole
lot of this he does to a degree but
that's really the only way he remembers
this device and so we're you know dawn
tries to take him out into the world and
tries to show him you know how great the
world is ultimately he says we need to
go find help because what's getting
ready to happen here it's going to be
something of immeasurable proportions
it's going to be a full-on invasion of
Earth and it will likely lead to the
destruction of everything that you know
and so alongside dawn because the Silver
Surfer has been gone from Earth for so
long he doesn't know exactly what it is
has taken place he doesn't know the
superhero landscape as it exists now
versus the way that he used to be and so
he immediately goes to the Baxter
building because of his mind the
Fantastic Four are still around the
issue is that as we know with amazing
spider-man the Fantastic Four I guess
Reed Richards and Susan storm are
presumably out in the multiverse with
Franklin basically making universes and
so we don't know what they're doing
right now we just simply know they're
not here not only that Parker Peter
Parker he basically bought the Baxter
building and turned it into a giant
monument to wait for the Fantastic
Four's return so we know they'll come
back at some point in time we simply
just don't really know when but because
of the fact that Silver Surfer is met
with this now he immediately says okay
well then let's go find you know whoever
else we can and he immediately goes to
visit Alicia masters and this is where
things this is where things get kind of
funny because for Dawn is she always
viewed herself as this you know one
significant person in the life of Silver
Surfer in the sense that he had taken
her on his board and he had shown her
all kinds of things in the universe and
feel for her it was a very very personal
a very intimate and a very amazing
experience but when they get to the
realm of Alicia masters Don basically
learns that all the stuff that the
Silver Surfer is done
he's already done for Alicia then so
Dawn's basically you know she has to
face the fact that she's like she's not
the silver surfers first I don't know if
it makes any sense but it's almost like
a woman who goes on a date with a man
you know and he's the most charming guy
in the world he takes her to all these
different places you know and these
places that he says are very near and
dear to his heart and then she comes
across an X and the X says yeah he did
that same thing for me you know and it's
just one of those one of those weird
situations and so there's really a lot
of jealousy here on behalf of Don you
know because she views Alicia as the
other girl not only that we know from
the history of Silver Surfer that he and
Alicia mashers were romantically
involved the two of them were lovers
after Alicia left Ben Grimm and so
because of this Don is of the opinion
that she may end up losing the surfer to
somebody else to possibly even Alicia
masters and so really like the dagger of
the heart with this particular situation
with Don feeling like she's being played
by the surfer the dagger and the heart
is that she finds a ring you know or at
least we see the Silver Surfer giving
Alicia masters a ring now the reason why
the Silver Surfer does this is that so
people can basically get a hold of him
if they need to but Don doesn't have one
now in truth Don never needed one
because she just traveled around with a
silver surfer everywhere he went
whereas Alicia masters was sitting in a
Soho loft in in New York you know making
clay models out of superheroes so who
only knew when she would need the Silver
Surfer but the idea here is that the
Silver Surfer basically leaves the
planet Earth and he travels to this
giant green orb which is a monstrous
version or a giant version of the one
the smaller one he had seen in the alien
spacecraft and comes across me
recognizes as the keeper of the great
knowledge but once he gets into once he
begins to question this keeper of course
he's attacked by Ben Grimm now this is
where things get a little crazy because
Ben Grimm doesn't know what's going on
Ben Grimm is not of his of his own mind
and so initially we would think that Ben
Grimm would make some kind of an
argument that he doesn't want to attack
Silver Surfer but he's being made to uh
he would you know recognize the Silver
Surfer in some former fashion but Dan
Slott plays it off like you know Ben
Grimm has no idea who the surfer is and
so I guess a good portion of this story
is really just you know this keeper of
knowledge effectively stripping earth of
its natural intelligence and effectively
making it a news
la not only that we actually learned
that this keeper of knowledge is keeper
of the history of his in la viens is
actually shallow ball herself who has
been reconstituted now as far as I'm
aware and if somebody knows they can
they can correct me on this but as far
as I'm aware this is the first time
we've seen shallow ball post secret Wars
and so it looks like she's been
recreated you know basically just exists
as kind of a faux and that's really
that's really what the kicker of Secret
Wars comes in is this kind of a free
pass from Alba to bring back the people
that they wanted to bring back and then
to maybe change them up a little bit
we're not really given any information
as to why Marvel simply like here's just
how she exists right now it may very
well be this just designed to be this
kind of huge love triangle between you
know Alicia masters and Shelley ball and
the Silver Surfer but what's really
funny about this you know is that with
Don Greenwood she initially you know
doesn't know who shall a ball is and of
course you know when Shana Ball says
either you side with us on zenn-la in
making earth a news in law or you stand
against us and you're considered a
traitor
of course he ends up siding with earth
but while Don is spending time with
Alicia masters Alicia also recognizes
who shall a ball is now a lot of this is
due to the fact that you know Alicia
there was a point whereby she spent a
lot of time in space and so she was with
Silver Surfer when he came across the
different iterations of mantis after her
death he was you know she was with the
Silver Surfer when he introduced her to
shallow ball who was his former love
interest as for a bride-to-be and so
Alicia knows a lot about about silver
surfers past because the two of them
have been very very close but Don
doesn't know any of this because a
silver surfer never told her every dawn
this is really kind of like a violation
of trust you know she really feels like
if she was that close to the silver
surfer the surfer should have told her
all these different things and so
ultimately dawn ends up you know telling
all these people in the world look you
know join me become part of LA and I
promise you all your ills will be fixed
those of you who are sick will be healed
where will we cure those of you who are
physically deformed will receive the
ability to reverse these deformations
your life will effectively go back to
the way it was we will go back to some
measure of perfection not only that we
also have dawn
me that shallow ball when was the former
betrothed the former wife to be of
Silver Surfer and so again this is
really all just too much for her to take
in and she's very overwhelmed by the
situation but ultimately Alicia masters
a sways her you know Alicia master says
hey look you know I don't need to see
the Silver Surfer to be able to hear his
voice to listen how he talks to hear how
he talks about you to know that he loves
you you know and so this was really just
dance law confirming for us that the
Silver Surfer absolutely loves dawn now
with a Silver Surfer he's not really
emotionless so much as he's not really
human in terms of his emotions and so we
wouldn't really see him acting out what
he considers to be affection or love in
the traditional sense but insofar as a
silver surfer is capable of love he
definitely loves dawn Greenwood and so
of course while New York itself is being
attacked the question is wherever the
superheroes be you know we're with the
Avengers we're when all these heroes be
and am at a massive cataclysm like this
and the question is answered almost
immediately now because of the fact that
the Silver Surfer has cosmic powers he's
basically able to eliminate those from
the influence of shala ball only insofar
as his ability to make contact with him
and so what he does is he effectively
puts a ring on Ben Grimm when shallow
balls distraction is given to the
Avengers and Ben Grimm's essentially
free of her control even if only for a
momentary second and so after giving Ben
Grimm a ring he alongside the rest of
the Avengers essentially fight off you
know all these foes of a shallow ball
now the some of these photos are aliens
from other other places but some of
these foes are also human who have sworn
allegiance to shall a ball and will
fight for her to the death it really
shows you how fast things turned pale
with regards to her trying to conquer
earth but ultimately we of course have
you know the Silver Surfer destroying
this massive construct which ultimately
leads you know to shell a ball basically
saying you are you're the absolute
traitor you know you have betrayed our
race and there's only one penalty that
can be that can be served for betraying
our race now our initial thought or
respond as we thought was oh my god you
know she's gonna try to kill the server
surfer but she said we said no um you
know we turn our back on you you know
it's basically this this thing where she
says you have the trades in law and the
only real punishment we can give you is
we're not going to like you anymore and
so they just don't talk to silver surfer
anymore and I said he's considered an
outcast by everybody who's ons in law
and so ultimately you know as a story
starts to wrap up we essentially have
you know the Avengers you know doing
what they can to face off against the
remnant forces of shallow ball but
ultimately there's really nothing left
you know in the sense of the the fact
that a silver surfer sides with Don
Greenwood he says you know of course yes
I care about you says she'll always be a
significant member of his life but aside
from that it's really just a silver
surfer to just sort of exploring the
world you know learning more about how
the world works getting a better
understanding of humanity now the kicker
about this is this these are things a
silver surfer has already done and so
I'm not really sure what direction it is
that Dan slots going with here just
because of the fact that you know after
silver surfer was come confined to earth
during the original Galactus saga of way
back in the nineteen nineteen sixties or
seventies I think it was his first run
in Marvel Comics his first volume of
Marvel Comics was literally him learning
about humanity so it's not like he's
really learning anything here
that he didn't know before but what we
also have is a dance slot effectively
tapping into some of the pre secret Wars
history and bringing back Nick Fury now
this will also be somebody that we
talked about and the unworthy Thor now
for those of you guys who didn't read
who didn't know about secret war I'm
sorry who didn't know about original sin
hired a secret Wars Nick Fury had killed
The Watcher and in return Nick Fury was
basically confined or doomed to che the
walker the watchers place by being
chained to the moon and he was forced to
simply just watch all things in
existence and so this is really just Dan
Slott saying yes Nick Fury is still here
Nick Fury is still around he will be
around now in terms of how he's
presented here is is designed to be
comedic in terms of how Jason Aaron
writes Sam he's a lot more badass and in
all honesty I really prefer what it is
that that Jason heir or at least how
Jason Aaron writes this so our rights uh
you know the Mighty Thor and how he
writes Nick Fury but ultimately this is
really just you know Nick Fury telling
Silver Surfer you're places on earth you
know you don't really have a home you're
not a Herald to Galactus you know you're
a man just kind of floating out of space
you have a woman back home who loves you
you need to go see her you know you need
to go to that woman and you need to
spend time with her and that's what
Surfer does you know he effectively goes
back and he ends up just spending time
you know with with Don greenwood and the
story will it just kind of gets left
from there he actually takes her to go
visit her mom and that of course leads
into the story arc itself but um the
only reason why I want to fill this out
here this isn't a story out story I
would normally do just because I thought
I was okay but the only reason why I
threw this out here is the
I also want to make sure you guys
recognize that yes a silver surfers back
the silver surfer is so